- [Narrator] My English instructor
teaches Richard Wright's Black Boy
as a masterful example of how an author
writes to reveal the emotions
of the story's protagonist.
Alright, that seems like a
reasonable way to write it,
but let's look at the other choices.
My English instructor
talks about Black Boy
like it's the best book ever,
because the author writes to reveal
the emotions of the story's protagonist.
Well the tone here just
seems too informal.
It might be how some folks talk,
but it isn't how you would
necessarily wanna write,
especially the rest of the sentence
doesn't have that informal tone.
Writes to reveal the emotions
of the story's protagonist.
This right over here, this part over here,
isn't an informal tone, so it feels weird
that the underlined
part would be informal.
So I would rule this one out.
My English instructor can't get enough
of Richard Wright's Black Boy
because she thinks it's a sweet example
of how an author writes to reveal
the emotions of the story's protagonist.
So this one feels even more informal.
So this one's even more informal.
More
informal.
You're saying because she
thinks it's a sweet example.
She can't get enough of
Richard Wright's book.
So this one I would definitely rule out.
That's going even a more extreme.
My English instructor revels in
the exploration of race relations
that Richard Wright employs in Black Boy,
because she luxuriates
in an author who writes
to reveal the emotions of
the story's protagonist.
So this choice over
here actually just feels
too official, too formal.
It's going in the
complete other direction,
and they're unnecessarily
using fancy words here.
Revels in the exploration
of race relations
that Richard Wright employs in Black Boy
because she luxuriates in an author.
So that just seems a
little bit over the top,
a little bit too formal.
So I would rule this out.
The best tone is actually what they have.
My English teacher teaches
Richard Wright's Black Boy
as a masterful example
of how an author writes
to reveal the emotions of
the story's protagonist.
And I wanna be clear.
Any of these choices, the
grammar is not correct.
Sorry, the grammar isn't incorrect,
but it's more about tone here.
That we really just wanna hit the tone
that we're not too informal
like these two choices
right over here, like these two choices,
and not too formal or kinda of
using too complex language or words
or more complex than we need to.
So I actually like it the
way that it's written.